[Musique]
RTL
Matin 7h48 Olivier mazol vous êtes avec
François baayot bonjour François baot
bonjour Est-ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
espèrent que le brexit sera une chance
pour relancer l'Europe et trouvez-vous
que les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
sont à la
hauteur le brexit est une chance de
clarification vous savez au fond depuis
le début de l'Union européenne en tout
cas depuis 40 ans il y a deux visions
qui s'affrontent
et les Britanniques qui viennent de
choisir de sortir étai les porteurs de
la première vision la première vision
c'est quoi c'est l'Europe c'est un
marché et le seul travail ou la
responsabilité principale en tout cas la
responsabilité première de ceux qui ont
la charge de l'Union européenne c'est de
permettre au marché de fonctionner le
plus librement possible et c'est
pourquoi on fait des normes vous savez
des règlements pour expliquer ce que
doit être être le moteur des tondeuses à
gazons le bruit des aspirateurs c'est
pas des choses méprisables comme on
croit mais vous voyez bien que ce sont
des choses secondes et la deuxième
vision dont la France en tout cas la
France au début de l'Union européenne
était la porteuse la deuxième vision
c'est l'Europe c'est ce qui nous permet
d'affronter ensemble les grands
problèmes de la planète les grands
problèmes politiques de la planète
qu'est-ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient
comment fait on pour ce pour
équilibrer les grands ensembles comme la
Chine qui par exemple veulent veulent
veulent se protéger pour leurs intérêts
ou les États-Unis comment équilibreton
ça estce est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que depuis que les Anglais ont
dit on s'en va cette seconde vision
celle d'une Europe politique qui peut
peser sur la marge des affaires du monde
est partagée par d'autres pays que la
France toute seule je pense que en tout
cas le poids c'est équilibré
c'est-à-dire que la la deuxième vision
nous étions un peu isolés et je suis
même pas sûr que les dirigeants français
de ces dernières années avaient
exactement cette vision à l'esprit mais
ça s'est équilibré à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne cependant faut pas se
dissimuler qu'il y a beaucoup de pays
qui continue à entretenir la première
vision alors madame Merkel vous la
situez où euh parce que celle le pivot
finalement aujourd'hui oui un peu
moins Angela Merkel et les chancelière
de la République fédérale d'Allemagne
elle était le pivot parce que elle
pouvait jouer entre français et anglais
et je crois que une part de de la vision
un peu sombre qu'elle a aujourd'hui
c'est que évidemment les Anglais est en
parti on ne peut plus avoir ce jeu de
bascule que de toute éternité
historiquement
l'Allemagne apprécie et donc le
cette l'obligation
désormais pour le chancelier allemand
c'est d'avoir un partenaire français
puissant la question est de savoir s'il
y a un partenaire français puissant s'il
y a à la tête de la France qui est en
effet redevenu une puissance centrale
s'il y a une vision et et une volonté de
l'exprimer pour l'instant et sur les 4
années et demi que nous venons de vivre
le moins que l'on puisse dire sans faire
de polémique inutile moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il a pas eu cette
vision mais il y a eu le barrage
allemand quand même parce que Madame
Merkel c'est l'austérité on l'a vu au
sujet de la Grèce c'est tous les
migrants ont le droit de venir en Europe
alors c'est parce que la France
n'existait pas à la hauteur où elle
devait exister que Madame Merkel a joué
un jeu solitaire et en effet pas
bienvenue quand Angela Merkel décide
toute seule des réfugiés et du volume de
réfugiés qu'elle va accueillir quand
elle va toute seule négocier avec le
président turc d'ailleurs au passage un
mot
un mot d'istanbou et de et du sentiment
de de tristesse et de solidarité qu'on
doit avoir devant
entre t nous tous pays qui sommes
menacés par ces attentats horribles il y
a combien plusieurs dizaines de mort à
l'aéroport d'istambou et beaucoup de
blessés donc une pensée pour eux mais
quand elle va toute seule négocier avec
le président turc elle ne fait pas œuvre
européenne et de ce point de vue-là si
la France est absente si la France est
dans son coin si la France est
reléguée en division qui compte moins et
bien à coup sûr
l'Allemagne prend du poids et joue pour
ses propres inér mais on voit tout de
même qu'il y a des élections l'an
prochain dans les deux pays en France et
en Allemagne on voit que du côté de
François Hollande B on porte beaucoup
d'intérêt à ce que disent les
socialistes allemands qui sont contre
Angela Merkel et Angela Merkel même
gouvernement elle reçoit Nicolas Sarkozi
bref elle est quand même peut-être tenté
aussi
de sentendre de sentendre plus avec la
droite française qu'avec la gauche
franais il faut avoir une chose à
l'esprit l'élection présidentielle de
2017 sera comme le scrutin du brexit en
Angleterre un référendum pour ou contre
l'Europe non sera un moment clé de
l'histoire contemporaine de l'Union
européenne ça sera le moment dans lequel
la France grand pays et futur grand pays
de l'Union EUR euréenne va dire quelle
est sa vision et c'est pourquoi en effet
le débat européen va être évidemment au
centre de la réflexion du pays des
débats des confrontations peut-être des
affrontements qui vont avoir lieu autour
de cette idée il y a des moments clés
pour les peuples et le moment de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 va
être un de ces moments clés pas
seulement pour ce sujet de l'Union
européenne mais simplement pour la
manière dont nous allons vivre ensemble
comment et la manière dont nous voyons
notre avenir et les grands choix comment
doit-elle se dérouler pour que le
président élu français sorti des urnes
puisse avoir un impact et une influence
forte sur la marche de l'Europe une
chose toute simple c'est le moment des
hommes d'État c'est le moment des gens
qui passent pas leur temps à ruser et à
faire du slalom entre les piquets
différents pour surtout qu'on ne sache
pas ce qu'il pense ou bien qu'il
choisissent d'aller à tout coup dans le
sens de l'opinion euh qui choisissent
d'aller à tout coup euh euh vers ce qui
flatent les gens mais c'est un moment où
on a besoin de gens qui aient une vision
qui puissent l'exprimer en tenant compte
de cette double nécessité la première
nécessité c'est nous sommes une nation
et nous voulons le rester l'Europe
c'est'est pas fait pour effacer les
nations l'Europe s'est fait pour les
souder pour qu'elles puissent ensemble
affronter l'avenir et euh de deuxè
deuxème
nécessité c'est qu'ils puisse exprimer
qu'ils aient un soutien populaire assez
large un soutien du corps électoral
assez large pour que cette vision
française soit une vision portée par le
peuple français dites-moi si je me
trompe quand je vous entends j'ai le
sentiment que le brexit vous donne envie
d'entrer dans la bataille de la
présidentielle d'exprimer ce que vous
venez de
dire directement sans passer Paris je
vais répéter tout ça simplement les
choses a pas parce qu'il s'est passé le
brexit entemps oui d'accord enfin pour
autant ma vision des choses est intacte
il y a des moments où les peuples ont
besoin de rassemblement nous vivons un
moment comme celui-là si à l'issue de la
primaire que je à laquelle vous savez je
n'apporte pas beaucoup de confiance et
de crédit mais si à l'issue de cette
primaire quelqu'un comme Alain Jupé qui
est capable de rassembler gagne son
Paris alors je l'aiderai je se je me je
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour l'aider mais
si jamais en effet ça n'est pas le cas
alors je ferai ce qu'il faut le bring
n'a pas changé votre Attitud faut non je
change assez peu d'attitude parce que
j'essaie d'avoir des convictions qui
sont des convictions stables au travers
du temps nous vivons dans un monde
politique vous le savez vous le voyez à
votre micro tous les jours où les gens
passent leur temps à changer d'avis à
changer d'attitude or on a besoin de
stabilité on a besoin de gens qui
sachent à peu près en tenant compte des
circonstances avec une capacité
d'adaptation mais qui sache à peu près
où ils veulent aller et où ils veulent
entraîner en tout cas conduire le pays
qui leur a fait confiance if it is not
Jup BA et bien vous voyez que vous
parlez anglais vous disiez que non mais
si merci beaucoup François beou Le
brexit est une chance de clarification
et c'est le moment des hommes d'État et
de ceux qui ont une vision viennent nous
dire François beou une dernière question
si vous le voulez bien monsieur bairou
est-ce que cela vous choque vous qui
êtes croyant et catholique qu'une
association proche de l'extrême droite
et de l'intégrisme comme religieux hein
comme siivita s'est obtenu son agrément
et puisse devenir un parti
politique euh je suis absolument alors
je suis croyant comme vous l'avez dit et
même pratiquant comme on dit
euh et je suis absolument opposé à
l'idée qu'on mélange religion et
politique écoutez franchement nous
passons notre temps à pointer du regard
l'islamisme euh à dire qu'il y a là
quelque chose qui est profondément
déstabilisateur et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire à ceux qui s'égarent dans cette
voie si chez nous nous nous mettons à
faire la même chose et à dire qu'il faut
que la vie politique la démocratie soit
commandée par la religion ça n'est pas
mon point de vue et je me battrai contre
comme citoyen attaché à la laïcité et
comme croyant attaché au fait que la foi
est une démarche personnelle et qui ne
doit pas être mélangée avec que la loi
le débat est donc lancé merci infiniment
à tous les deux